[Music]
in repent of your sin news o submitted
by sugar tits
what is a sugar Ted I heard it so many
times
hey sugar tits the Chinese pastry with a
little jujube on top a preacher is
facing murder charges after killing his
wife to avoid the shame of divorcing her
oh that makes logical rather have the
shame of murder than divorce the
priorities I guess in the Lord's eyes
divorce is acceptable if the woman is
pulling you away from Jesus Christ
himself oh really yeah the sound of I
didn't know divorce was okay in
Christianity yeah is it coholic or is it
Christian a Christian I'm not Catholic
though I know Christians like if the
divorce is like the reason for is
because the whoever the spouse is is
pulling you away from Christ whatever
that reason yam you have to go through
counseling that's a great excuse the
wife keeps want to have sex during
church time then you could I just get an
annulment and it doesn't exist ever oh
so a divorce it's us like on record that
you guys were together and annulment
means is dissipated it never existed but
then isn't there like a certain amount
of times a year
dude that no man yeah I don't know
probably maybe the first year some [ __ ]
I think well I'm not sure how long this
couple was married for but this dude
doesn't even even he's 44 years old
schoolbus - he has been charged with
premeditated first-degree murder after
his wife Amy was found dead in 2016
lying in her bedroom floor in a pool of
her blood with a gunshot shot wound on
the right side of her head he tried to
make it look like it was a suicide
ballistics [ __ ] yep there was no
gunpowder in her hand
mhm she was right-handed but the gun was
found near her left hands
I'm glad a stupid stupid pastor Steve is
stupid very stupid because then they did
forensics tests and they saw like
footprints that were wiped with that
bloody footprints I were it cleaned off
and there were pasture shoes to your
pasture shoes they have crosses on the
bottom they're like dr. Scholl's
like an orthopedic purpose yeah gotta
stand a while yeah yeah I know exactly
they're kind of like round on the tip
right but then it's also a nice letter
so you can wear with slacks I've tried
on those shoes like she was like that
before holy [ __ ] they're comfortable
holy I kind of want one now what school
don't say that I'm gonna buy them for
you for your birthday
I dare you just like just to find shoes
for a costume and there's like these
purple shoes and they're like super
comfy what does it posture Pete or
orthopedic whatever the [ __ ] they were
so [ __ ] comfortable doing it so it
was amazing but but it was like 80 bucks
and I'm not doing that [ __ ] for a
[ __ ] costume I looks ugly as [ __ ] -
it was not too bad I want to wear all
the out like every single item of
clothing that says please don't [ __ ] me
well you got the fanny pack
there you go I got him the perfect fanny
pack for him I need those sandals that
are also like they're not Crocs but
they're kind of like the woven sandals
that are all the Moses sandals no but
then but then they're like kind of geeky
like all velcro and got straps on the
ankles around the ankles for extra
support you can't have a pair of those
yeah there's surfer shoes but if you
wear them properly but the way he wants
to know I'm talking about the one where
it looks like a basket on this side here
in a Belko here it's hiking sandals
almost hiking sandal
and with white white Swiss on so I said
the motor sandals that's call those
little Moses I know but it has but has
to look techie because the leather one's
kind of cool oh dude we got to get you a
roller bag dude yeah and then you have
to wear the denim long shorts with a
belt a tight tight belt and then tuck
your t-shirt into it with two buttons
that I button to the top I'd be really
though I would probably have a roller
bag if it didn't make so much noise so
people want my ass not surprised though
don't say it like we'd be like what's
wrong with an element I'll have you know
that you know how dope elements are you
know how dope they are I know if you try
to buy it all but you can't even find it
because everybody's trying to keep it
that's how dope it is or it broke down
before like I don't want anyone to know
it had it they are Honda's they never
break down Honda's are invincible
exactly there are the Nokia's of the car
world
how much [ __ ] was received in a [ __ ]
out a lot in a row you want a bet a lot
because the seats fall backwards f is a
lot of trunk space where you gonna put a
bed there so yes the most comfortable
car [ __ ] on earth this is your
spokesman right here yeah give it to him
you deserve it no idea how don't
elements aren't now I understand that my
element so far has had to go to the shop
seven times yeah and the only reason why
is because the person who fixed it
before thought they did a great job they
did a terrible job
it's [ __ ] duct tape and rocks all
brand-new parts but they're all wrong
dumbass oh it's not the cars fault that
mechanic was like hey he's like so
here's the good news you have new parts
here's the bad news they're all wrong
[ __ ] all right so what happened so this
guy got charged so they found out that
it was him because as well so he went on
the dark web like a pastor knows how to
go on the dark web
the kind that [ __ ] touches kids and I
will say this he's a little bit weird
because I believe if I remember
correctly murder is also really bad sin
right yeah so he wanted he didn't want
to be married anymore but he didn't want
to face that shame in the church because
he became some sort of elder in the
church
so he could not get divorced that's why
he went to the dark web to see if you
can hire someone to kill his wife for
him he negotiated a six thousand dollar
fee you took with this one of they're
calling it besa mafia that's a mafia
well later on down the line
Besant mafia was hacked and its customer
list was exposed to the FBI so that's
how they were able to link it that it
was the pastor that wanted me dead
because the pastor's username on the
dark web was dogged a God who was a
pastor at ba-ba-ba church she's that
full on the dark web he was thinking
about so many different usernames as in
men this one's not this this one taken
because that's time creator for it to be
like just a regular username you dark
day God dog day
God oh one word you can't think of a
[ __ ] different name that doesn't give
away your [ __ ] profession yeah really
big black man 87 holiday so they linked
in Makati Asian 42 I thought that when
you go to the dock where you hide your
IP and all that stuff yeah but he made
the fatal mistake of leaving a unique 35
karat Bitcoin code on his iPhone that
was later matched against the same
transaction and that he paid besan
Lofton he stopped Bitcoin and this guy's
oh 44 but this besa mafia group they
were pretty much scamming the dude
because they kept telling him like oh we
attempted the murder this time in place
but for this reason we couldn't kill her
so you need to pay us more and so they
kept trying to like fish out more money
at mark smart so finally he was like
okay [ __ ] that I'm not going with them
anymore so then now with the FBI or what
the police is saying that he might have
just taken matters into his own his own
hands and set it up to look like a
suicide because he was the one that
called 911 later on that night when he
discovered her and he was just like
voice shaking yet calmly saying like oh
there's been a suicide it was a fake
assassin crew they just keep siphoning
money out of people and say we'll do it
later
that's what it seems like the Fen
there's also neighbor
that witnessed these two vehicles that
just get off from the property around
the same time that she was killed
and so maybe they did do the hit but the
point is they can link the the murderer
to him because of the cryptocurrency
yeah Wow
they do have FBI lurked in the dark web
all the time though have a nine-year-old
son by the way oh we've never got to ask
like that I think the important question
asked is what does she do
and what the [ __ ] how big of a [ __ ] was
she does you have to be a pretty big
mystery to worry I don't think that's
the right question to be asking for
because if she is a bigger like the
biggest [ __ ] ever then she yes come on
undo that face cuz you know it's true
points where you looked at Kasich you're
like I want to [ __ ] murder you know I
mean and what part of your brain is like
you know what I can't go through with
the shame of divorce that's when the
religion [ __ ] goes wrong because he
had like all this pressure of like well
I'm an elder now I have to do this I'm
not either the church yeah all this
pressure being put down I'm within his
probably threw himself you know what I
notice now I already know you're not a
this is not a Korean church because the
Korean people would he give a [ __ ]
where's maiya stephen erlewine
yep what would it look like dan was like
a serial killer [ __ ] you know like
Korean churches are so funny you know
what there's like one stereotype like
negative stereotyped about Korean
churches there's always a story about
the pastor marrying the piano girl
everybody go away oh really
we're like running away from the church
like having an affair with the piano
girl and then leaving his wife and
leaving the church I've known I could
name already three or four churches that
had that situation afternoon it's so
sexy piano [ __ ] man
I thought the stereotype was creators
always split let's do two they did say
let's make like a Korean church and
split or like the women of Korean church
is always gossip oh this is creepy
general all churches no ask you or women
in Korean church is always trying to
hook their daughters up with your son no
that's all the preacher not a pastor's
the same [ __ ]
I don't know I feel like any church that
has that the word elder is really
[ __ ] sketch like it just means that
they're they're more organized oh so
there's different I mean there's
churches where like they've been around
for hundreds of years and then they have
colleges universities hospitals and they
have a whole structure and they run it
like a company oh but then I think
David's David's dad is like an
independent right so it's almost like
having one store that's your your church
so like Presbyterian churches have
elders and so though they're just a
board and committee so whatever money
comes to the church they all have to
decide collectively where it goes within
the church so it's actually really
really smart instead of having a pastor
to sign everything you know so even the
pastor doesn't have much choice either
so if the pastor wants to do something
they have to go to the elders to ask
them through funding what they can do
yeah they have treasurers they have what
deacons and you know different that
there's different titles but it's it's
ran more like a like a democratic
government then a church with the pastor
who's the dictator
yeah or preacher or whatever yeah how
many years that they sentence him well
he's just been charged at this point
they haven't sentenced him yet he looks
like he'll do fine on trial oh yeah
right
[Music]